we have become the largest party
so i also think i am prime minister
should have been
I also said to theonderhandelingstafel
that I think I should be and that I should
well you know
that it cannot be taken from you
you do need support from all parties
and who will not support that
well I am not going to mention names
you have to find out for yourself
but there was 1 party that said wholeheartedly
and that was the party of Mrs.
van der Plas who said
fine as far as I'm concerned you are going to be
there was 1 party that said
well we prefer not to
but we are not going to submit it
and there was 1 party that said
in the extra parliamentary form
no way
but in the end you have to make the choice
is your own position as prime minister
where many people
voted for
and also expected me to be
and I understand all those people too
I am just as angry as she is
or do you choose
yes then again if it is not possible as it should
then it should be as possible
and then continue in 1 cabinet
1 legal cabinet
where you like a lot of the Netherlands
and before you get voters done
or
break do not continue
and then maybe that
Frans Timmermans or 1 other cabinet is coming
so in the end
with no matter how much it hurts
and no matter how unjust I am
find and how
constitutionally incorrect it is
I have made the decision to
then not to choose my own position